well we know x is janet's speed.
when we first started solving problem we wanted to find janet's speed.
so we let janet's speed or her rate equal x.
we didn't know it.from there we were able to fill in the other pieces of information.
we knew janet's distance and rohan's distance and we also knew that rohan traveled 20 mph faster than janet.
once we have these 4 pieces of information we were able to write expressions for each of the person's time.
we knew janet's time 250/x.and rohan's time 300/x+20.
and since they both spend the same amount of time traveling we can say janet's time equal to rohan's time.
we took the equation we saw for x which is janet's speed.
100 mph.so if this was janet's speed then we know rohan's speed as well.
he traveled 20 mph faster than janet.
so we just add on 20 to janet's speed which equals 120 mph for rohan.